hey everybody welcome to the Rubin
report I'm Dave Rubin and we've got two
great guests for you this week miss
Wendy Liebman and mr. Paul case and this
is YouTube so let's get right to it
obviously the big the big story of last
week and what's going to be the big
story for the next couple months is the
Boston Marathon terror attack and all
the fallout after that we're gonna be
dealing with trials and just a whole
mess of stuff but I wanted to focus on
the media angle here because that in a
weird way became a bigger story than the
actual attacks themselves so CNN was the
one that really took it on the chin so
to speak let's jump in and watch a
little bit of their coverage say this on
TV but this is a good time when TV
unfolds wait maybe faster so there is a
difference between the identification
which everyone can confirm now right
everyone to say that so this may be look
very different in about an hour if we
learned that there has been no arrests
but the good news is is that least
there's an identification of an
individual taken into custody without an
arrest right so this is all the
terminology but I have actually three
separate sources but two that are very
highly placed and close to the
investigation that have just told me
that there has been no arrests and in
fact the suspect has not been identified
by name yet that they have they're
looking for someone but they don't have
anybody in custody yet and they don't
have
identification okay so we basically had
four days of that reporting one thing
and then finding out it wasn't true an
hour later or the big thing was we don't
want to speculate and now we will
speculate so my first question for you
guys is has the media just lost control
of breaking news altogether in an age of
Twitter can the media operate in the
old-school way that we we think it used
to well didn't do we win the presidency
one year over Truman like remember when
they ran that newspaper he did at least
for a day in one paper right right I
think people are always rushing to have
the conclusion because we need answers
really quickly so maybe it's a game of
telephone and people get the wrong
information yeah does it seem worse now
though because of Twitter because
everyone can do it it's not like a
newspaper is gonna run a story and
that's the only way we're gonna get it
look at world it's a woman who said I
probably shouldn't say this on
television yeah automatically she was
like I'm just guessing and she also said
you know in two hours this might change
she basically said I don't really know
what I'm saying I'm just gonna say it
just in case yeah so you know she is
rushing nice she looks so eager yeah we
did the first we did the first we do
difference before somebody tweeted it or
before it was on Facebook or you know
right you can see it every face right
and everyone else is just on board for
that
yeah so partly it's that they all want
to be first but how much is it do you
think is just like this endless ego
running you know you mean they're on TV
they want to say something and they want
the clip that's gonna then go viral
right who broke the story like it's just
pure ego it seems oh you go and
advertising they were a little bit tuned
in to their station so that they can
have better at when you break it first
and everyone's can trust you more but I
mean you're right it is easygoing most
people who tweet shouldn't even be
tweeting anyway they're just it's all
ego it's all ego-driven who cares what
you have to say necessarily why do you
have to make that say well thank you you
have to say too but my point is the idea
that what you have to say is is
important or more important than someone
else
yeah and that clip is an example of that
too you know it's like it's just so fast
for no
really yeah just calm down a minute well
one of the things I kept thinking as I
was watching all the coverage is how you
know something horrific happened and
obviously deserved a lot of attention
but then immediately we forget every
other bit of news that we've been
talking about endlessly so for a week
North Korea didn't have nukes anymore
you know you mean the day before that
was 18 stories on Drudge we're gonna get
nuked and then for a week we didn't hear
about it so as part of the problem that
the news cycle just keeps us in this
constant state of fear and wanting more
information in China one of the days
where over a hundred people died and
yeah a little blip and that's it well
the good news is you can just turn it
off yeah I did
yeah and I followed Twitter a little bit
and I got bits and pieces from trusted
news sources you know it's like it
depends who you follow to and you know
this to teach history don't you sorry
sometimes so I mean it really is like
who do you believe right yeah
is there also a problem with you know I
was watching CNN and you know they're
all it's like you got wolf and he's so
stiff and then everybody has their
little John King seems a little drunk
sometimes but one of the things I was
watching is Anderson Anderson Cooper
who's like the darling of everything is
there a problem that he has a daytime
talk show although I guess since it's
it's been cancelled but it's not off the
area she seems a little absurd to me but
it's like he's talking about Snooki and
all and honey booboo during the day and
then and then at night he's talking
about this serious stuff and it kind of
seems a little ridiculous does that seem
legit kind of like me being here talking
something and then telling jokes about
my hair yeah - in a way that there is
something like why should I you're
talking about honey boo boo what do you
really know about this but there's also
something I think that makes people
comfortable that they're like oh we know
you because you talked about honey boo
boo earlier today what else is he saying
so it depends on the viewer I suppose
yeah right yeah I guess we want them to
all be better and not be so drunk and
you know well that's the other thing you
know poor Jake Tapper they got him up at
like 3:00 in the morning and you know
then the guy has to be on air first
hours and then we expect every word to
come out of his mouth to be perfect he's
the one who did the obscenities right
away and got fired oh do you know what I
mean that was the local that was the
local story yeah if you guys didn't hear
about that there was a guy in North
Dakota on NBC affiliate who literally
the first two words out of his mouth in
his career on camera were [ __ ] [ __ ]
we can say we can say it he said [ __ ]
[ __ ] and they fired him immediately
although I was watching TV well he was
nervous do you mean trying to pronounce
someone's name and I think he got
flustered like you couldn't say and he
was like [ __ ] [ __ ] and the woman who
was the co-anchor was like and she's
tried to talk and all the sudden you
could you see her give up and choose the
guy but talk about about yourself
getting fired on your first day on the
job Cheri Oteri when she was on Saturday
Night Live one of her earlier
appearances she said [ __ ] and that got
her all this attention I don't know if
she got fine it's so funny because they
find people in different professions
like in in sports but they don't find us
well and you know when they find people
for entertainment purposes the guy I
think I don't I know nothing about
sports so there was I think it was a Red
Sox game where somebody this week said
something about like we're [ __ ]
Boston over David Ortiz and they're not
finding him be said because they said
his heart was with Boston or something
like that it's like what you make those
rules from the right place after this
whole thing all right well the point is
CNN even if you're exactly even if your
coverage was [ __ ] [ __ ] nobody got
nobody said it on air and I guess that's
the important thing
bonobos comm is the official outfitter
of the Reuben report use code TRR 2-0
for 20% off your first purchase